i
[Música]
a
con un objetivo principal se dio inicio
en italia a la jornada internacional de
la donación de sangre sensibilizar la
opinión pública de la importancia de
hacer donaciones periódicas para
garantizar la seguridad la calidad y la
disponibilidad de la sangre y de los
productos sanguíneos para los pacientes
que los necesitan este año la
organización mundial de la salud ha
encargado este evento a italia país
anfitrión el ministerio italiano de la
salud con el apoyo de organizaciones no
gubernamentales como la cruz roja
internacional han organizado eventos en
las principales ciudades del país en
roma' la capital una cumbre
internacional se llevará a cabo con
expect air expertos científicos de
diferentes países en la noche el coliseo
romano se iluminará de rojo y en todo el
país los centros de donación estarán
abiertos incentivando a jóvenes y
adultos a donar sangre
[Música]
cada año en eeuu cerca de 68 millones de
personas donan sangre en 2.500 centros
de donación sin embargo menos del 38 por
ciento de la población estadounidense es
elegible para donarla según datos de la
cruz roja en total se recogen cada año
aproximadamente 13 a 6 millones de
unidades de sangre una cifra que en
ocasiones se queda corta para la demanda
que hay y que ha hecho que varios
centros paguen a sus ciudadanos
calificados cerca de 50 dólares por
donación de sangre e incentivos
económicos que también se están usando
en las campañas de vacunación contra el
coi donde para tratar de lograr la
inmunidad de rebaño se están dando pagos
directos subsidios de transporte
descuentos en almacenes de cadena y la
posibilidad de incluso de ganarse becas
universitarias
[Música]
la donación de sangre en paraguay ha
disminuido en un 20% debido a la
pandemia del cob y 19 según cifras
oficiales del centro nacional de
servicios de sangre en años anteriores
he llegado a un promedio de 90 mil
donantes voluntarios por año este 2020
siguió solo a 70 mil la cifra preocupa
al gobierno debido a que el país
necesita al menos 100 mil donantes
voluntarios por año para cubrir una
mínima necesidad para combatir estos
ministerios de salud está impulsando una
campaña que implica salir a las calles a
las empresas en los parques a fin de
buscar a personas y convencerlos de que
la donación salva vidas por otro lado a
pesar de esta disminución general de la
donación de sangre la donación de plasma
convaleciente por parte de pacientes
recuperados de coronavirus ha
significado un alivio para centenares de
personas que reciben este tratamiento
experimental en paraguay según el
ministerio de salud pública la
utilización de plasma convaleciente en
pacientes con kobe 19 reduce hasta en un
38% las chances de ser internado en una
terapia intensiva
[Música]